yeah as usual I don't really know if I'm
alive or not this is my common problem
anyway i hope i am live and this is why
I'm welcoming you to this live stream
one hour of blitz cubed sing we see I'm
probably going to play a couple of games
i really like to play some games myself
i have to say that today something
absolutely stupid happened i was
recording some games for my own channel
and I recall it for more than one hour
and then I actually found out that I
didn't switch on the sound so I recorded
six hours of six and six games of blitz
without any commentary yeah I had no
sound was really great I had to delete
this so I'm going to go play a couple of
blitz games and let's see if i get a
five-minute opponent here here we go I
got white against cervical man cervical
man from Switzerland gap enter played
eform for a change the room and let's
see he's going for the main line the
marshal maybe on some classical stuff
let's see yeah the classical main line
not the marshal yeah the brea they all
copy what Magnus Carlsen place yeah
which is in general not a bad idea he
knows what he's doing um I usually play
in the five-minute pool here and there
are some games but you can challenge me
sure g6 hmm i don't really know exactly
how this is going to be played I think
this is an effector line
this is Bishop g5g to business okay so
we're going to have a closed center here
I want to control C fighter possible but
he took aha so am I going to play be for
now he has Knight b6 to c4 that's not a
not a good idea hmm I don't know and add
tricky not not so easy to play I'm used
to this position from the from the black
side this kind of thing yeah does it
make sense to accept gambits and let's
wrap it John if it depends of course
some gambits you really should should
accept if it is not a good line a good
opening you have to try to hear that
evening blitz and grab the material
there is no clear clear-cut way to do it
my idea is to play b4 and c4 I think you
can change the quality in twitch if you
feel that you feel that it is better to
UM to reduce it a little bit my attend I
did I was b4 and c4 possibly rook c1 and
then get the queenside play going this
is quite okay for white i would say i
would like i like to play wide in this
position I have
that I did not expect okay let's do that
before it's just good I think night a
for I play C for 97 98 back years is
running into rook c1 and then see form
there should be three then see form yeah
it is just nice for why nothing ok so
what c4 or Bishop e3 first i guess i
should play Bishop e3 first and now he
runs right into this one the checking a
six now the very nice position for white
unless I'm overlooking something
sometimes tend to do it with this
interface that are not used to the Blitz
an interface is there and it wise to
play higher rated opponents yeah aqui
advice if you play a higher rated
opponent is to just play what you what
you can not do something out of the
ordinary if you are an aggressive
attacking player try to play like that
if you want more though yeah let's say
strategic player here trying to prepare
things then do do the same against the
strong player try to play to your to
your strength and don't really take into
account that much who you are facing
this is a very important thing okay he
is activating here with the Queen I
wonder what a good setup is maybe look
to be too yeah look at you be to to
protect the pawn Bishop to e3 and night
to d2 possibly i have this very nice
extra pawn
yeah there seemed to be some technical
issues I don't really I'm really not an
expert on the one on twitch there so I
cannot help I have no all around
favorite food food I like I like spanish
stuff a lot in recent years um yeah I
preferred the white here because I had
more space and the clearer plans yeah
white has some had more opportunities to
open up the position one big problem was
that the bishop on f8 and the knight on
f6 they're doing that much and I had the
advantage on the queenside and there was
really am no big play that black-haired
he have night a force answered by look
before
ok so I'm going to try to use my my
nights on the queenside now no rosemont
our party for me look a 2 and the queen
is trapped isn't it I don't see a square
that's it yeah there is nothing very
common to eat in Germany it is we are
very much influenced by by foreign food
iam okay yeah maybe some meat and potato
or something' is something that would be
classically german but it's not them not
happening that much okay and i know
rosemont our party does carnival around
but i just am I just worked all day no
partying with the next game M Western I
am strong ahem let's see how he's doing
a form going for Sicilian there is a
question do you think it's a good idea
to sometimes bluff and chess yes I think
it is sometimes it is really a good idea
within reason but it is sometimes
helpful with the sometimes time
management can be a useful tool them you
know that you it looks like you know
what you're doing but you really don't
ok so d 4 is kind of interesting didn't
expect that move mixing systems here ok
c3 interesting
it's um however something a position
type that is well known in this and this
opening ok I'm going to try to get
counter play against the d4 pawn did
they ever reach the shaft novela the
Royal game in English I did sir royal
game in English I didn't know that this
is the the the English title yes I did
but it's very long ago I mean like 25
years ago when I was at school I really
barely remember the details ok hmm he's
not afraid of night f form ok I'm going
to prepare that don't either for
immediately didn't didn't do much
someone either for where's he going
actually this is nice for me I mean it
looks nice the Queen here doesn't have
many great squares yeah this sound but
it really looks bad I thought taking a
93 looks bad can also take on e5 maybe
okay 93 piece a g4 maybe this might blow
up in my face nicely okay I'm just going
back that sets a simple way to do it the
tech III and keep a 5 attacked okay so
he just countered at x e6 okay I'm going
to take you three this isn't a porn porn
so we got that one back and still at x
e6 hmm so this one maybe I'm getting
getting to the end game with equal
material but I have the bishop Pam and
I'm attacking the important be to pawn
why is he thinking here maybe you got a
phone call and then or something there's
a question am I expressive over the
board like a spiral yeah nobody is
expressive as Kasparov i guess but yeah
I mean I probably more expressive than
the total pokerface people but not very
much okay let's see how do I do that no
hmm he's somehow keeping his stuff
together here
amazing I don't see how to to break
through here with my my pieces and he's
may be intending to get the king / king
of 132 remarkable
h5 King f1 bishop age 6 king e 2 and
then what I can take detune well that's
it's very tricky actually very tricky
stuff so ok now I can go to c3 yets
that's that's important not not losing
the night but what now Bishop h6 is
helping or not oh can I can i attack be
three more i don't see how i should be
594 maybe this this is actually ok my
Isis see nemesis is Oleg us yes I have
the worst possible score against them
like nothing it really nothing I even
have a better score against a much
stronger players against him I have no
score really no score so my bishop air
is nice and i'm going to open oops open
the position for it Bishop c3 coming
trying to come up with that
the real problem here is the time I'm
pretty much down here on time
yeah would be difficult to do something
with this little time left well 115 I'm
sorry I really i thought i was i was
some more behind him yeah check for
Bishop f4 furthering Bishop f4 winning a
piece and if you move to the night i
have also king c4 try to pick up the
queenside the other two bishops are
quite nice I have them against the
artboard imanam on- form all mine is
three or something something like that
it's not so terrible okay let's see
whether night is going trying to get to
the default on I don't know if Bishop f4
was that great actually now that I think
of it
now I tricked me night a 7 what a move I
didn't know our city was that really
nice
18 seconds left yeah going to liquidate
all the pawns he offered me a draw nice
enough he could have one on time maybe i
can probably get all the pawns i don't
see how he prevents that yeah i had a
hair suddenly had a winning endgame here
but um i couldn't i didn't manage to win
it ok so let's seem the worst message
someone has sent to me honesty i cannot
recall it didn't get that many am i
didn't get that money many a bad message
is really i normally just send out a
message to rise the c-4 complained and
it's helping ok playing voodoo spiral
here doing opening requests ok this guy
plays a six and b6 so let's see i'm
going to try to get some attack against
this let's see how is continuing ok i'm
going to to play for a quick attack IAM
and help it it's going to work let's see
how to how to get this attack going
quickly looking one I can play
yeah their money many good continuations
that that look that look dangerous
should be three maybe four Bishop deform
yeah trying to trade off his Bishop here
and get the night to a good square on on
default his position here is not so bad
despite them the somewhat creates the
opening the King on g7 disser does make
some sense it's not it's not not that
that terrible now Quincy five for the
possible move that might happen okay so
let's see he might have nighty for him
yeah maybe yes 94 but whatever it's it's
not easy to play 94 might come
King e7 you're really going to go to the
queenside it's really doing that okay
hmm interesting yeah I'm going to
sacrifice on b5 definitely only a
question when yeah let's do it come on
this is just blitz chess so let's
sacrifice them it's got 94 coming yeah
this is really not not that great okay
but he can give a check their thats it's
really all a six is what I want to play
but he probably has Bishop a sex okay
going to wait to just take that and play
a six really want to want to get near
skin night comes to seafoam problem I
was thinking maybe come to a five or
something and I once i had f6 let's do
f6 and now if I take what is this move
Queen B seven maybe mmm yeah probably
but I have to do is have to do something
Queen here so I have to protect you too
for up t6
okay he's got this chick rookie three
awesome yeah yeah I'm not going to
survive that one unfortunately after
this wacky opening which really should
be punished no I played this badly
simply okay yeah I didn't really a few
this this kind of opening okay it's a
bit difficult there are so many
questions sometimes trying to get a new
game that's a question explain or what
color you put your pants when playing
with the bishop pair where this night in
bishop there is no no rule to to do that
the question if one were to put a black
wrap it around my book what would you
recommend to play against the English um
difficult there's no clear answer to
that really probably something based on
e5 so for the AB sorry going for the
Sicilian here playing guerreros da Luz
I've got very strong opponents here
2,400 after 2400 so I'm playing them the
kalashnikov variation here against this
Brazilian I am and he is playing in line
without c4 with those early night moves
and here i can mostly rely on normal
development nothing fancy going on okay
so i put a knight on d5 the dead in
itself it's not a huge deal what do i do
now night to see 5 as a question how do
you deal with people who are obnoxious
are want to prove that they are better
than you during analysis especially
after draw after you beat them I don't
know if people are somewhat obnoxious
and analysis I just stop the analysis
it's no point I mean very often nowadays
some you often want to look at the game
with the computer rather than with your
opponent we've got any more over here
often if you just check it with an
engine um so on another question is the
Sicilian business the solution that I
have for the awful lion that I hit play
in the way no not really it's just that
I'm i played i wanted to play this line
anyway this Kalashnikov and now there's
a book out of it I'm what I want I'm
going to to look at this a little bit
more okay this the take on b5 hmm not
very nice
hmm and it's not a nice position b5 is
attacked and what do I do here it's not
very comfortable rook be eight he's got
Luke a six and that's not looking good
ma'am that's not a good position
yeah f5s was clear but what what can you
do I don't know what the new line is
going to be that i planed our way
looking looking around I'm going to do
the viewer games the the channel viewer
games very shortly I am I'm going to
finish my little series on my way your
cat tournament this week and then I'm
going to do the viewer games many
interesting games to you there's some
brief argument there about the book I
was referring to this book about the
solution Ian Kalashnikov called the
killer Sicilian catchy title by Tony
rotella there's someone mentioning they
don't trust books by players without
Freda titles I understand your point but
nowadays with chess engines even a
non-title players really able to write a
good book and this is a good book
definitely Tony rotella he knows what
he's talking about his decent in
correspondence chess by the way and it's
really different to what was to how it
was years ago when really it was a
business of analyzing everything on your
own nowadays some wit with both engines
is different even not as strong players
they are able to write a good book okay
rook a6 going to try to get the c3 porn
I have my nights always need to be
pointed to to the left I have this kind
of stuff yeah the last part of my video
is the ugly part it will be ugly I can
promise you that I really played those
games badly but my opponents played very
well so it was still interesting to look
at
ah what kind of position is that it just
covers this hmm the night has no squares
iam what a rotten position
I don't see a good continuation here
simply I'm just busted he played this
very well
okay so he took these six and nothing
that I could do about it
yeah I know that doesn't look very
inspiring but what was I supposed to do
I don't know that's probably not working
but my position is lost anyway I his CS
ways to refute that bishops no not even
not that one yeah maybe maybe I can do
that yeah start completely ridiculous
that's a funny question of course i
never stopped on the street the people
knew me or anything no it happened at
chess events sometimes that people say
okay i'll do the guy with the youtube
channel that this happens okay so he's
attacking this and protecting here so
that's it now that wasn't a good game
really need to play more focused yep
let's get it going the mainland Queens
gambit declined is much less 0 than semi
Slav yeah the Queens gambit decline is
very decent opening against avoids only
somewhat sometimes it's a little bit
passive but if you play it right that
doesn't doesn't need to be um there's
also a question about my book writing
experience was it fun was it stressful
it wasn't really stressful it was very
interesting and what I have to say is
though that it took much longer than
originally thought and it's really
helpful to get to having having made
this experience I think if i'm going to
write another book which might happen
i'm not really sure about it but if I do
I really will benefit from this this
learning experience so I will I will
probably be much quicker and
maybe you ride the better book yes I
have a Wikipedia entry I know starting
with IM level they they give you one and
i got one as well so it's nice to have i
guess for advertising purposes in a way
okay so this is an early almost end game
type of position where white is enjoying
some some space advantage but how am I
going to play it not so easy i'm going
to play f3 possibly g-form to gain space
and try to use the space to my advantage
I could have played be five actually hmm
it could have played b5 I missed that
chance but okay I really know where
there is no concrete plan for a next
book it's just that it might happen that
i'm going to write second one but um
there is no definite thing planned first
of all I need the the the the current
project to be completely finished I am
finished it is some submitted everything
but it is still um it needs to be be be
published finally there's a question any
tournaments coming up for me know next
tournament will be in them in the summer
probably a book a book on the red team
yeah it's very difficult to work to
write a book on the ready system because
of the the move orders
okay so I have some some pressure here
on the H file he always has Knight f6
bag okay do I go F for here or how do I
play here g 4g for to gain even more
space maybe take now the real issue is
it's all nice and good but how are you
going to i know i know i know what i'm
going to do he took with the bishop yeah
g5 is very helpful winning a piece okay
okay i'm going to play an unrated game
now guys against our walker yeah i know
it's a huge rating disparity but I
actually owe the guy again so I'm going
to play it yeah this is um he played a
very nice game last time last term last
Wednesday when I played the been to
blitz and he really got me so so close
to him to a defeat so that I said okay
we're going to have a rematch but it
didn't get one last Wednesday so I'm
going to do this now am I going to visit
eastern Germany soon yes very likely
very likely i'm thinking about playing a
tournament in the summer actually in in
in poland and this will mean that i'm
going to drive through eastern germany
and probably visit Leipzig and dressed
and those the cities but it's nothing
definite yet you so we have the oops my
mouse is acting up we have the
Kalashnikov again airwalker not skywalk
i am air welcome
I'm thinking of playing the Polonia
tournament inin in rod slough if this is
the right pronunciation
after whom is the Kalashnikov name yeah
yeah obviously I'm it's related to this
this weapon but it's a it's very
difficult to tell it's and it's not
about a player and maybe because it
looks similar to to the weapon it won't
know it's a weird term it's a weird
weird name not a very attractive name
actually hmm I don't really think a
t-shirt with the GDR on it ddr the
German Democratic I don't really would
consider it offensive I mean don't turn
don't don't think so I really wouldn't
care so much if someone would wear that
they can wear whatever they want within
reason ok so I have a pretty normal
position here but what am I going to do
g6 yeah maybe
let's see what is going to do playing
for f4 here I know one thing he's really
taking his time which might prove
difficult at the end it really brilliant
struck him let's see Bishop e3 okay
that's not a bad spot for the bishop
maybe putting some pressure on d6 hmm
galit centralizes night shouldn't be bad
there's an idol of memorial in warsaw
and interesting I don't know when I
didn't didn't see that when I was
looking for tournaments I'm i would be
interested in that ok so let's see how
am I going to play this if I take a row
take with the Queen unfortunately that's
not so nice hmm
now anyway to get the night to deform
don't see that ok I'm going to secure my
night on c5 yeah in the night of
memorial one should play the night off
there is some sense to that I admit that
hmm going to play for i really i really
wonder how am I going to play that maybe
the bishop here 2c 69 36 or something
it's not a very great position ready the
bishop on g5 is kind of not doing much
hmm the night of memorial you say is the
first half of July this is also when
this tournament in rots laughs is
happening so I doubted us the exact same
time would be weird timing but maybe ok
I'm going to take here now if he takes
on d5 l'd take on there for maybe he may
be he will sacrifice the exchange for
Queen deform Wow Bishop f4 look at four
year for Queen D 5f z FF 6 ok
yeah I'm he's putting up a pretty great
fire rating of 1600 I mean all nice and
good but he's really doing a good job
here playing 495 if he takes okay I'm
glad they're getting in 95 he will take
on g6 so I have to cover that first and
now i have worked c7 to g7 as a defense
i hope
h5 I can play g5 so it's not is Bishop
f5 hmm 94 maybe who f-5e I can play f5
of course that's much better that's much
better now I have it habit under control
with almost taking on g6 it's not a big
deal now he's actually opening up the H
file then for me okay so if i go to age
seven he is going to take on g6 maybe
yeah anyway look age for Queen edge form
now you can you can take on age 45 and
so on ah come on a how why are you
playing so well it's not fair yeah roop
shifts unbelievable stuff it's then
you're taking g six year right cannot
believe it
it could have one with ruchi six I think
oh oh okay yeah i mean it's it's almost
unbelievable how well he played that but
very nice very nice okay I'd really
don't know what happened here but ok
going to play a a new five minute per
game he really spank me down 1600 rating
I don't know what happened here night I
don't think he's using using an engine
just to just a good game okay let's um
let's play a new a new game them from
the from the pool playing taxi yeah I
don't really remember who that is I did
at one point let me check i want to
check who that is no name store okay
this question do I sometimes have to
force myself to do videos for the
channel or is it always a pleasure it is
some pleasure almost all the time I
really enjoy to do the videos the only
things that are sometimes a bit tricky I
do though some I do those tournament
coverages though some those games of the
day and around recaps and stuff like
that and sometimes it is tricky to do
those simply when you do this in the
evening and the round was taking a long
time and you start at 11 and so on and
then it's really really really late and
then as sometimes think okay hello do I
really need to do that but what can you
do it just it's just part of the job
let's say um what this is really the
only the only time when I when I think
okay really now
okay he put his night on before it's
always interesting it's an open question
often if this is a good piece on before
or bad piece I wasn't sure in this case
I played the bishop back to be 1 i'm
going to centralize play 45 now i am
1992 um my favorite players hmm i have
probably have a couple probably always
liked carpus games very difficult to
understand too that day sometimes
difficult to understand so okay i'm
going to check i didn't want to have
this this closed position and always
also liked Kramnik especially in his
some younger years when he was playing a
bit more aggressively he is he in a way
got back to this style in recent years
but at one point he was playing very
very conservatively but when he was
playing more enterprisingly and a little
bit like he is doing at the moment i
would I know what the Berlin is very
boring but he has an interesting games
quite often there was a question one
exactly is my book coming out probably
April like two months from now
not sure if there's a most underrated
opening there are some really good
openings that have moved order issues
for example one is six on d4 is a very
good move but one is six can only be
played by French defense players this is
why lots of players shy away from
employing the move okay night beehive is
not good okay if it weren't for the
French I think many more people would
actually play one e six against you for
maybe me included I don't really play
the French but it is some e success is
quite nice that's a question what is
more boring the building or the Petrov
pretty clearly in my mind the the petty
officer is the less interesting opening
because it doesn't have any complexities
in porn chains the burl indus is
actually not not totally boring in terms
of structures just a very it's a bit
one-sided because you have the Queen's
off so early you never get any attacking
game so on or something like that it's
just always this kind of complicated
interesting end game it's not really
boring in a sense it's just it's just a
bit one-dimensional it's always this the
same kind of queenless own position
okay trying to get something going but
black plate is very well I have future
strategic issues in this position age 59
I can even take that but okay if I don't
play that what exactly is my idea okay
I'm going to do this one yeah black
plate this very nicely my pieces are all
badly placed and now aged six and g5 is
just good ruk you can play the petrol
for win it's not impossible but the the
thing that sometimes not very exciting
about the Petrov is that you never have
any nem exciting pawn chains or complex
things happening strategically it's very
often a purely a calculation heavier
thing whatever otten position here yeah
what a bad position is really remarkably
bad and very well played by my opponent
he never never stood any chance he
played it very nicely yeah he totally
outplayed me here this Bishop Bishop
before and stuff
it's really really bad if I go King g2
he might even play on the long diagonal
with Bishop e7 what a bad position yeah
the pet shop is not a not a bad opening
at all what is this guy doing to me yeah
i mean i mean i'm really not saying when
losing all good and nice but he's
completely whacking waking me here rook
g4 look she's free that's amazing how
I'm getting destroyed here in this
position remarkable ok at least I get to
to double the rooks it's not really
threatening much but at least I get this
done can I check here you might take
with the Queen add the rookie singing ok
it's really it's really really bad young
and what is going for nighty form wow
this guy is trying to completely
completely annihilate me and
successfully queen txt for now what to
see do now who care for probably so I'm
two pawns down and have a bad position
great but I have more time on the clock
for for once I really don't know why but
I have more time on the clock
okay so I'm sort of still hanging on
here position is this is lost but
somehow not not resign able now probably
this reasonable amazingly bad
disposition
yeah I'm going to resign that this is
this is useless even if he has 15
seconds I was just completely destroyed
in this game this was really bad are
there any any questions that should be
answered let's see yeah well the Petrov
is not a bad opening as I mentioned
going to play one more game and that's
the final one for tonight I guess for
the one hour of blitz I don't ok that's
a question my nephew is getting into
chess jab ok mmm the question is is he's
getting into chess and got to a high
level one trophies yeah should your kids
courage to nephew to to train and so on
yeah why not i mean chasm a good good
pastime it's something that it teaches
you lots of useful things and I mean the
question if this is some an idea for
your nephew to took up to take up as a
job is something that will arise at a
totally different time it is just a
hobby or nice thing to do and thinking
about it is being more or this this
thought is coming at a totally different
time so he has to reach a certain level
when to think about that I don't really
think it's such a terrible idea to do
chess for a living it's just that just
that you really have to know what you're
doing and it's not a bad idea to have
some kind of backup plan like if you
want to earn your money with chess to
have learn the proper job or so is this
not a bad idea I think in case it's not
not working um
why the english opening is not so
popular if you mean 1c4 then because of
a hive the thing is that with white you
very often want the position where you
actually have an advantage in space and
with c4 and black playing 'if I've quite
often I'm black will get an advantage in
space it isn't it amazingly difficult to
earn good money with chess yet is you
cannot get rich this way you can get
along but you cannot really expect to
earn them to earn a lot especially when
you just them when you are just playing
the game with tournaments this is a very
difficult actually to get get anywhere
with the teaching and what what I'm
doing you can get along you won't get
rich but it's something to do when you
want to do something that you really
like to do and you don't want to sit in
an office all day which I did for 18
years so I was thinking ok let me do
something else there there should be
other things that that I can do and I'm
glad to to having chosen that way and in
case you wonder yes I played my my
passive Rui Lopez again
simply because I didn't know what to do
and my advantage that I have with this
line as passive as it is I have played
it so often that actually can play some
quick moves as your see I'm ahead on the
clock and quite often white also needs
some time to play what I mean he needs
to think a little bit to really get
somewhere with just with some quick
moves it's often not it's often not
enough yeah I'm kind of blocking his
attempts IAM pretty pretty easily yeah
and no this is this is a bit like
smoking yeah this is kind of variation
it's a bad habit you know it's not good
for you but still you sort of do it
sometimes I'm not ya head quit smoking
while ago but this line is so it's a
little bit a little bit like like an
addiction and you know you should quit
it but you know ok maybe I can get the
get the Queen traded he regroup to the
night 33 in fact this is a good idea
because quite often Black is able to
sacrifice on c4 this is something that i
will take into account i would put our
he's giving me the e 56 where that's
nice let me think about it this actually
changes the flavor of the game a little
bit ok i still go here i have night a
for which she has to attend to I think I
thought she has to attend to this move
but he does not agree maybe
if i take night a 491 okay I'm going to
do it no 95 interesting so I'm going to
take now or not harm I will get me five
in can i play Bishop g4 actually 95
Bishop e2 work actually nice I
definitely won't play this line anymore
in tournament chess I'm really over that
it was just that I was routinely putting
out the rears black and I didn't I was a
saying okay what am i doing okay I'm
just playing it again whatever ok so now
i can grab him and i have two night Sam
okay so going to play with age six
getting a passer want to get the past
porn him so when he wants to play king d
4 + 93 possibly but still I'm able to
get this going g5g for Bishop d7 bishop
see 886 bishop c 8 a-6 might be what he
wants to do hmmm that's really true
do I have to play Knight b6 I don't want
to but that maybe have to have covers
see aid interesting that's not a bad
position I think
King age four and g5 is what I want to
do okay King edge from is he going to
play King f4 and then wait with the king
it's going to be it's going to be
dangerous for him definitely he will be
able to play King f5 f6 but my point is
quick so g5g for is coming that might be
a pretty good position really again okay
if i push it now 92 maybe I'd careful so
I can g5 I mean sorry and I'm going from
them oh he's actually doing that so now
night here right because he has to
attend with the King c3 and the pawn so
this will be hard to do night c7 I take
on c3 oops oops Hey okay like here let's
take this oh he's allowing me to trade
here do I get do I get the pawn I guess
I do oh oh e five
pigs d6 I can just about stop it there
should be four no no no no is he really
going to do do that to me him he says
was check I know I screwed that up it's
with check its was check its much check
I know oh that was the set was as
disappointing you know really grinded
him down here in this position totally
yeah how do I win actually King of Kings
you five I guess right King g5 and win
so how do I win here let me check on or
its nightly to actually enough I yes he
has the c5 yeah probably 91 I don't know
but ok that's a at the end of this end
of this broadcast it really nicely
tricked me at the end with the with a
person I am okay um let's see can the
Trump offski be played as a main weapon
against Knight f6 sure of course not a
bad opening at all so it said it saves
lots of theoretical work load if you
play the trump here to play the Queens
gambit let's send it from you have a
good opening repertoire ok I hope you
enjoyed this live stream one hour of
blitz they have been streams who have
played better but I hope you're still
enjoyed it could answer a couple of
question help it was enjoyable ok I'll
be back next week I think
same day same time I put out an
announcement video though to make sure
yeah thanks for watching and that's it
i'm off have a nice day